foreign
dude
roses
here is
delete
[Music]
the volume
what we're seeing is is being repeated
what I saw in Nikolai what I saw in
Odessa last week with my own eyes is
being repeated across many uh big cities
in Ukraine this morning again equivali
uh an apartment building was hit people
had been killed uh are still under the
rubble I have also issued a statement
about that over the weekend again in the
knee Pro it's constant in in her son and
also uh over the weekend in kharkeep we
are present in almost all of these
places and if we're not physically
present we're very close by just down
the road so whether it's the new world
or query this morning you know when
agencies the ngos local volunteers
continue to respond of course with
immediate support which is which is
shelter uh and but a lot of times it's
also more and more that psychosocial
psychosocial support so what this means
is that the needs of population are
increasing they're not decreasing
since the beginning of Russia's brutal
full-scale invasion of Ukraine the
International Community has been clear
over 140 countries have repeatedly
condemned the Russian Federation for its
aggression against Ukraine and demanded
that Russia withdraw its military forces
from Ukraine's internationally
recognized territory